about the ability to influence and
persuade yeah okay
you can't put yourself out there into
the world and be known for what you
really are because you don't know how to
influence and persuade people you can't
get customers you can't get suppliers
you can't get people to join your team
the better you are at communicating your
why people will want to work for you
regardless of the opportunity that you
afford them rise and shine it's in
spresso time what's that believe nation
it's Evan my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference in the world
so let's start your day off right grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
learn to influence and persuade over to
you Jordan Belfort Warren Buffett was
doing the speech of Bill Gates about
maybe 10 years ago and he was asked by a
college student what can we do as
students to make ourselves more valuable
in the workplace
so you think Warren Buffett would say
learn how to pick stocks or investments
you know whatever he would say not what
he says he says go out and take a course
in sales and cos allocation day he did
Dale Carnegie change his lighting you go
now that point because he took they said
I took Dale Kearney changement without
that you don't he'd be without that
course yeah he'd be the richest money
manager in Omaha Nebraska then no one
ever heard of yeah Annie met his wife
that way but the loves is like because
without the ability to influence and
persuade your Kanaks you can't put
yourself out there into the world and be
known for what you really are so listen
as an entrepreneur if you do not know
how to influence and persuade your
company is done this is a challenge for
so many entrepreneurs you have a great
mission you have a great message you're
trying to do things for the right reason
you're not just trying to make money
making money is important but it's not
number one does something else that you
try to accomplish but because you don't
know how to influence and persuade
people you can't get customers you can't
get suppliers you can't keep people to
join your team you can't get media
coverage you can't get the traction that
you need because you cannot do this
thing all alone it's impossible to do
any business all alone even if even if
you're the only person in your company
you still need to sell to people right
you still need the ability to be able to
influence and persuade and I love that
more than I love this the term is
selling I think people often associate
selling with something negative which it
can be it has a slimy connotation
sometimes for some people but the
ability to influence and persuade it
doesn't mean you're pushing people to do
something that is against their own best
interests it's the exact opposite I mean
you can use influence persuade to hurt
people I want you to use it for the
positive what I do all day long is just
see people and their their genius level
talent I see you as being Michael Jordan
level talent at whatever it is you want
how to do you have that ability and my
entire goal is to move you from where
you are right now with these limitations
and this belief system to playing up
here to play in a bigger game it's why I
make these videos every single day and
hopefully I'm able to move enough of you
then that makes a difference and so I
want that same thing for you you want to
make a powerful positive impact in the
world to do that you need the ability to
move people you need the ability to
influence and persuade or your company
is not gonna go anywhere so let me give
you three simple ways on how to do it
for your company right now
number one is transfer emotion you have
to understand this is where so many
people get locked up it's not about the
specific words that you say it's about
transferring emotion it's about you
feeling something in here you feel it
this is really important and then making
the other person also feel that it's
really important one of the best advice
that I got from my agent who helped me
with my YouTube channel and get and get
better if there are thousands of videos
well as he kept saying raise the stakes
raise the stakes raise the stakes make
it more important make me feel something
I was so concerned about getting the
specific words out right that it came
across as boring and memorized and
robotic and without care we're way more
important than memorizing those words is
the energy is me feeling like this is
important because if I feel it you guys
will feel it too if in whatever you're
creating especially if it's video
content but regardless if it's video if
it's face-to-face if it's written
content you have to feel the words this
has to be important
this has to be life-changing if you feel
that your message is life-changing then
it will be for
some people but if you are just so
worried about getting the words out that
every little mistake you freak out and
you don't have confidence in your voice
you're gonna lose you won't bring people
along I like to say that when I'm 85
percent sure I'm a hundred percent sure
because you can never be a hundred
percent sure looking forward only
backwards what why go from 85 100 is
because if you have confidence then your
confidence will bring people along board
with you if you're 85% and you act like
eighty-five percent people will tag on
to that 15 percent of uncertainty and
they won't make a decision even if it's
in their own best interest even if they
are letting themselves down they won't
act because you're uncertain because if
you have uncertainty in the advice that
you are giving then they will have
uncertainty and they won't do it they
won't take action so the ability to
influence persuade starts number one
with the ability to transfer emotion to
transfer energy to transfer certainty
you have to feel the message first and
then they will too tip number two is
study people who are great at it just
like any other skill that you want to
learn study the people who are great at
influencing and persuading and here's
the side note to it even the people who
you hate so Jordan Belfort is a great
example I think of all the videos and
all the people that I do Jordan Belfort
gets amongst the most hate because of
you went to jail people don't like that
I featured a criminal on my channel
great there's a lot from all the people
that I profiled that I that I don't want
to learn from you know I may not want to
be a father like Steve Jobs but there's
a lot that I can learn from him where do
you completely hate Jordan Belfort as a
man or not you can still learn from him
if you love Jordan Belfort great if you
hate him great when you can unbox
yourself to say I'm only gonna learn
from from this kind of person this
really limited way of learning that's
the only way I'm gonna learn and say I
can learn for anybody who could teach me
and even if I absolutely hate that
person they still have something to
teach me I'm gonna I'm gonna ignore all
the stuff that I hate from them and I'm
gonna take that one thing it's gonna
make me better when you can learn to
learn from the people that you hate
that's when you really grow because they
might have one thing that can make you
the best version of you and that's the
only thing that you should be focused on
and tip number three is to practice
practice practice the more you do it the
better you're gonna get out like
everything else ever always use the
ability in even little tiny micro
situations whether it's with your
brothers or sisters or kids or parents
spouses or boyfriends or girlfriends or
classmates or customers or partners of
suppliers or investors always try always
always push things a little bit more
think about what you want from them
here's the game that I always play
what's in their best interest the person
who I'm talking to what's in their best
interests I try not to be a little Evan
voice on their shoulder I try to be the
best version of them on their shoulder I
try to tell them the thing that they
should be telling themselves that they
want to be telling themselves and I give
them the confidence to be able to go off
and do the thing that they want to do
and so when you catch it when you
recognize it when you see it when you
see that this person is letting themself
down in some way when you see that this
is the thing that they should be off and
doing then you may not need to go
hardcore on them and freak out and rage
on the home practice practice take your
baby steps but just practice doing it
try some of the techniques that you've
learned try transform better emotion try
modeling more success and see what
technique suits really well for you and
the more you practice just like
everything else the better you're gonna
get I think this is a skill like
everything else I think is a skill you
can learn I think if you tell yourself
that you suck at influencing people then
then you will forever and always what if
you say you know what I may not be good
at it right now but it's a skill that I
want to learn then you can get better at
it now we've got a really special bonus
clip that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that question of the day I want
to know who do you think is the best
that we featured on this channel or
somebody that you look up to and really
have learned from who is the best at
being able to influence and persuade for
people who want to build their skill
sets and model success learn from the
best who should they be modeling leaving
the comments below thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso and enjoy
the bonus clip
they spray so give me what you'll find
is that that the better you are at
communicating your why people will want
to work for you regardless of the
opportunity that you afford them like
they want to be a part of it yeah we do
a little thing which we've been doing
for years and years and years called a
give and take whenever there's any kind
of relationship whether it's a an
outside partnership or even somebody who
joins our team we do something called a
give-and-take where we want somebody to
be selfish and selfless within the
relationship so not give and get but
give and take so we'll ask them what is
it that you have to give to us that you
have that you think that we need right
and they'll tell us and then we'll say
great what is it that you selfishly want
from us and we want them to tell us what
they can get from us and when those when
those things match you have a balanced
relationship because so example I've had
it with people you know they'll tell me
what they what they have to offer and
that's awesome because that's what I
want and then they'll say what they have
what they want to take and they go oh I
want to work with smart people I'm like
plenty of smart people what is it you
want to take from me they're like I want
to help build something wonderful do
that anywhere what do you want to take
selfishly from me that you can get into
awesome if they can't answer the
question
I won't engage in a relationship and the
reason is because in time the
relationship is unbalanced they're gonna
be giving but they're not taking and I
don't even know how to give them what
they want then they'll complain they're
not making enough money or that because
it's not balance that's right
selling is something you'll always do
the rest of your life most people don't
like selling some people like to kind of
make it nice and sound we use a better
word and say communication or diss its
sales by the way those that just turn
off the video and don't want to watch
about what selling has to do hey you
want to marry that girl you love you
know which one I'm talking about you
need to sell her and her parents and her
best friend that's all selling you want
to get that promotion purely selling
baby and those who get that promotion
sell better than you do that's why it is
they don't sell a car their job could be
human resource or something but they
learn how to sell themselves
as that position more than you maybe you
oughta learn how to do it'll benefit you
make you a lot of money long ones long
yeah yeah the most important work ever
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
up or that would be like a little beacon
hey believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details